we are hanging out with the gorgeous
talented
just special thoughtful and totally rad
molly sims
and of course one of our favorite
booties tick-tock star
and our dear friend etan bernath
hi eton how are you today good nice to
meet you both i'm super excited to be
here
we injured mad watch time but very nice
well you have two ladies in red
flanking you and may i say aton today's
outfit
chef's kit thank you yes i'm super
excited to
talk to you guys and eat about uh some
traditional holiday foods
well eitan i'm always mesmerized when
you talk
about food knowledge history facts
so you go for it because i love when you
do this so
you're on thank you let's go so we have
a fruitcake over here and they're very
traditional
in these kind of tins so let's just pop
it out now
i've actually never had a fruitcake but
some fun facts about fruitcake are is
they originated
in medieval times the romans actually
used these
as a kind of snack the roman soldiers
they kind of just like kept it in their
little armor
it stores very easily it lasts a long
time it is full of nuts dried fruit
spices even sometimes a little bit of
booze and
i've never had it before but let's give
it a try it's very traditional for
christmas
uh it was originated and popularized in
the 18th and 19th century and then it
was mass produced and shipped out
in the 20th century where it's now a
christmas treat
okay first of all so good i like it
second of all roman soldiers 18th
century
thank you for that fun fact there you go
that's why i'm here next up this one's a
personal favorite
we have some latkes this is traditional
for the holiday of hanukkah
in my house my dad has always made our
latkes this year i developed the recipe
for my youtube channel
that i think might beat him so we were
having a latke off this year
and uh i'm very excited to see who wins
oh my god it's so good
while you're trying it these originated
in eastern europe and the oil used to
find the latkes symbolizes
the oil that burned for eight days and
eight nights in
the temple in jerusalem and for me i
personally never need an excuse to eat
more fried food
but for the general population it's a
very easy excuse to eat a lot of fried
food and i'm all about
it wow i didn't realize so the latkes
are tied into
the eight nights of hanukkah yes
i love vlogkas i love
like blintzes potato pancakes a lot
because
i i i can't get enough of it now
let's talk about eggnog as a jewish boy
i actually never had eggnog we didn't
drink it growing up but
it's made of cream milk spices uh a lot
of times also has goose in it like rum
um of course mine does not you know but
uh it is super flavorful super delicious
and it was eaten by
the ancient british and uh it was
considered like kind of like a
drink for the wealthy because the
ingredients in it were considered very
like prosperous like things that only
wealthy people had
so really
2020 ending with our drink yeah really i
should take a shower in this
um what um molly were you always
a fan of eggnog or did you have to
acquire the taste
you know my grandmother on my dad's side
we called her grand
she made such a homemade amazing eggnog
it wasn't it wasn't too sweet but it
wasn't
she also didn't make it too thick i
don't like it when it's like i can
hardly swallow it so
i kind of always been a fan of eggnog i
do i love it
i'm actually now drinking a nut nog um
from good milk which is a really good
kind of like
oh that's fantastic because oat milk and
almond milk is
all the rage and it's nice to know i
didn't know that there was an
alternative
molly see do you have this on your site
i do actually um i love this company
it's called good milk it's an
almond they have almond oats and it's
really really good and i topped it with
a little bit of cinnamon i don't know if
you guys can see right here but
so good i was always totally grossed out
by eggnog as a kid i did not understand
why anyone could drink it
cut to 45 loving it
well eitan i always love learning things
and it's like you make me look at food
differently
and it is just such a pleasure and
such a spirit lifter to hang out with
both of you today
so much and i really have to recommend
before we go that
both of you write a book eitan because
you are so spirited
so knowledgeable and you have such
whimsy in the way that you
tell your stories about cooking and food
and molly
you really really are an incredible
writer
and you bring us into your storytelling
and it has so much heart and so much
humor my two favorite things so
merry christmas please write a book both
of you guys
merry christmas thanks guys
you